c'est plein hier à la télévision de voir
son spectacle d'été sa tournée d'été des
programmes et cette tournée d'été dans
le sud de la france elle est organisée
par var matin et son patron jean marc
pastorino selon jean marie bigard il
aurait été déprogrammée de cette tournée
d'été en raison d'une d'une blague
à mon avis vraiment pas drôle peut-être
même plus que ça et on va en parler
qu'il avait fait sur la chaîne ces 8
dans l'émission cyril hanouna ne touche
pas à mon poste alors pour prendre les
choses dans l'ordre
on va d'abord écouter la réaction de
jean marie bigard hier sur ces 8
déplorant cette déprogrammation vous
allez voir il a l'air spécialement
touchée en quelques heures j'ai eu un
million de vues de gens qui venaient à
mon secours
donc j'ai envie de dire merci jean-marc
pastorino qu'elle organise la bavarde
oncle le patron de var matin il m'a
châtiés avec un seul et unique argument
qui est à mon avis doit pouvoir passer
sous le coup de la loi
c'est de dire on peut pas prendre un mec
qui a raconté la blague de la déchirure
à la télé alors avant d'écouter votre
point de vue sur fr2 précision la
première c'est que le jean marc
pastorino question le patron de
var-matin dit c'est pas vrai nous
n'avions pas signé de contrat avec jean
marie bigard donc on ne l'a pas
déprogrammé on l'avait simplement
approché et on n'a pas donné suite
et puis pour que vous puissiez vous
faire une idée par vous même vous allez
voir le
le texte cette blague je pense
spécialement envie de vouloir diffuser à
l'antenne donc vous vous contenterez si
vous voulez bien de la lire si vous le
souhaitez la question qu'on avait envie
de se poser c'est est est ce qu'on a le
droit de faire ce genre de blagues à la
télévision où est-ce que ça doit être
sanctionné ou censurés d'une manière ou
d'une autre que la chartier alors moi je
trouve très très bien très sain qui
effectivement aujourd'hui on réagisse à
ce type de blagues en effet parce qu'il
se trouve que jean marie bigard avait
déjà lâché raconter cette même
blagounette il ya quelques années et il
me semble aussi dans l'émission
d'hanouna entre autres il n'y avait pas
eu effectivement de réaction donc là on
voit bien qu'il ya une évolution des
mentalités effectivement très
probablement lié amis tous et
franchement je m'en réjouis parce que il
est presque pathétique fin dans son dans
son intervention la gauche venait de
montrer ils ne mesurent pas que
quelqu'un comme lui qui effectivement
connu dans une émission en prime time
balancer ce genre de blagues salaces à
une heure de grande écoute
effectivement ça veut dire quelque chose
ça une porte et ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que ça minimise totalement
ce que décrit sa blague c'est à dire un
viol et viol mais vraiment et avec
violence ça minimise et ça nourrit un
climat de tolérance que très souvent on
gosses en disant bon allez c'est pas
grave
allez on rigole etc nous vivons
effectivement dans une société qui est
très tolérante envers les violences
qu'on appelle sexistes et les violences
envers les femmes et ça peut être aussi
envers les autres individus en règle
générale est qu'il est temps de se
rendre compte de ça c'est à dire que les
blagues ça minimise sa nourrice au
climat de tolérance qui ensuite vont en
fait donné des éléments aux agresseurs
pour dire regarde il se passe rien je
veux dire ça c'est marrant je peux aller
plus loin et c'est absolument vérifier
par les gens qui travaillent sur ces
questions là qui sont au contact et de
victimes et d'agresser banalise et sur
sur twitter on vous a posé la question
trouvez vous la déprogrammation des
spectacles de jean marie bigard mérité
ces noms à 74%
voici deux réactions complètement
opposées n'est là qui nous dit les
blagues les séries tv les films ne sont
pas là pour moraliser la société l'art
la fiction peuvent se permettre
d'échapper aux règles
s'impose dans la vraie vie alors que sur
lefigaro.fr monsieur babineau nous dit
jean marie bigard a fait une blague
sexiste grossière inacceptable aucune
compassion pour lui c'est johan
surenchérit renchérit plutôt la blague
n'en est pas une c'est abject et immonde
olivier pas bon tout aussi dire que
c'est une forme de censure c'est à dire
qu' il ya des choses qu'on peut qu'on
peut plus dire à la télévision à ce que
c'est
est ce que c'est un progrès alors déjà
ce qui est drôle c'est qu'il ya une ce
qu'on appelle vous savez en
communication en effet streisand
c'est à dire que en sanctionnant cette
blague puis on l'a pas dit où on a pu la
lire si on le voulait mais en fait tout
le monde va finir par aller la voir
finalement cette blague force qu'est
l'art à elle n'aurait pas eu on pourrait
dire un tel retentissement
personnellement j'avais pas je regarde
pas la télévision je n'avais pas eu vent
de cette formidable at the same j'aurais
survécu sans ça sans doute mais là du
coup tout le monde va la connaître
bon et peut-être que ça fait
paradoxalement la publicité au spectacle
de monsieur bigard la deuxième idée
c'est que je crois qu'il ya toujours eu
des modalités quand même de filtres des
programmes grand public ne serait ce que
l'on raconte pas les mêmes choses à un
moment où il ya des enfants ou pas les
sanctions etc
bon voilà ça me paraît assez normal
maintenant la vraie question c'est la
liberté d'expression de façon générale à
travers des spectacles qui nous ont
pourrais dire on est relativement
prévenu de ce qu'on va voir
et moi alors je sais que c'est des
sujets évidemment compliqué c'est le
sujet très délicat autour de la violence
faite aux femmes évidemment ou là où la
culture du viol
on a pu parler mais moi je suis pour le
principe c'est effectivement la liberté
d'expression et j'ai extrêmement pas moi
j'ai très peur d'espèces de forme de néo
puritanisme petit à petit on va pouvoir
exactement comme finalement facebook
nous cache l'origine du monde de courbet
parce que ce n'est plus et ans on peut
plus voir ce genre de choses petit à
petit on n'aura plus le droit que
d'autoriser pourrait dire certaines
heures ten d'orthodoxie qui correspond
aux dogmes progressistes du moment et ça
ça me gêne profondément d'abord parce
que là il s'agit pas d' art il s'agit de
finacle humoristique on est bien
d'accord c'est l'autre chose mais disons
que de façon générale les expressions
artistiques sont là aussi elles ont une
forme de catharsis
elles ont une forme ou pas c'est une
forme aussi de d'expression des
déviances et des transgressions
probablement pour pouvoir pas forcément
les faire en société là c'est un peu
comme sur les jeux vidéo la morale écrit
la blague
on navigue n'ont rien à voir avec y'a
pas de mots rien à voir et là avec ta
morale c'est mon but
richard houis votre point de vue là
dessus je vous donne au passage des
réactions d'internautes parce qu'ils
sont intéressantes comme toujours
bigard et le grossier de service nous
des citoyens payeurs c'est lui qui va
payer pour les autres qui eux sans odeur
de sainteté dans le showbiz et ne sont
jamais inquiétés et philippe nous dit
bigard et peut-être vulgaire mais il est
quand même mais quand il est invité dans
l'émission la plus vulgaire du paf
il est juste dans le ton on rappellera
qu'il était dans touche pas à mon poste
l'émission de cyril hanouna
qu'en pense le président des évêques de
france mans je présente peut-être qu'il
avait un bon point de vue sur sur cette
situation
moi j'avoue que je suis je suis un peu
gêné à plusieurs niveaux d'abord sur la
manière dont finalement les choses sont
présentées à priori a pas de sujet
puisque le sujet initial c'est bigard
10g était déprogrammé et le responsable
de var matin dit il n'y a pas eu des
programmations puisqu'il n'y avait pas
de contractualisation il était quand
même d'un prêt bigard très très avancés
dont la poule avec oui mais c'est parce
que dit pourquoi la parole de bigard est
plus importante que la parole du
responsable de var-matin sert qu'on dit
à un moment donné il ya deux sons de
cloche
prenons les deux sons de cloche à dire
sur le hayon est ce que ce serait juste
essayé de le déprogrammer c'est autre
chose maintenant totalement là un truc
est plus une fiction qui est alors on
part du principe qu'il ya effectivement
une déprogrammation pour cette raison là
et on a intérêt et on interroge ça c'est
exactement la même chose et donc on se
met dans cette fiction de fait parce
qu'on n'a pas assez tenant là est en
tout cas les deux versions ne disent pas
ça
qu'est ce que raconte moi qu'est ce que
raconte cette blague moi j'entends la
liberté d'expression j'entends la
création l'art etc mais souvent vous
l'avez dit vous parlez de spectacle dans
lequel on installe quelque chose dans
lequel on peut mettre des garde-fous
dans lequel on a le temps un moment
donné de dire aux grands au public là je
dérape mais en gros je reviens et
j'explique pourquoi le dérapage et je
peux faire en gros quelque chose là il a
rien qui est fait et justifie sa blague
salem il ne va pas pour le coup avec des
pincettes et on est dans un moment où
depuis trois semaines on y dit on arrive
vers le 8 mars et le 8 mars est la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes et à un moment donné on nous
redit que les violences dont sont
victimes les femmes
c'est un fait de société important ça
doit même est une priorité des
politiques publiques et
ne s'interrogerait pas sur cette blague
qui à un moment donné
vu comme ça je ne sais pas dans un autre
contexte que raconte cette blague mais
elle raconte pas grand chose de drôle
mais je mets mais c'est quelque chose
d'hyper violent et dans lequel c'est
normal un moment donné que la société
réagissent et c'est pas un côté plus dit
bon c'est juste où sont aujourd'hui les
barrières six ans gromit ou a eu quelque
chose c'est de nous dire il ya des
barrières à un moment donné il ya tant
de femmes qui ont connu des situations
analogues peut-être pas dans le même
contexte que à un moment donné il faut
peut-être s'interroger sur ce que ça
raconte est-ce que ça a dit merci au
respect de l'individu ça n'a rien à voir
avec cela si vous avez un commentaire to
très brève
moi je vais de trèbes est d'abord je
trouve parce que je suis sur le bête
mais j'ai pas trouvé la blague drôle
pour commencer et la deuxième la
deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
j'ai regardé cette émission on voit ce
coming bigard pleurer parce qu'il avait
un million de vues j'ai trouvé ça
pathétique
en fait c'est l'émission je vous donnais
mon expression excuse moi je vais
employer son langage me fait gerber
alors alors juste un peu que vous moi je
ne regarde pas la télé et je le regrette
pas et ça me fait regretter la télé
peyrefitte service le service le sommet
univers soit là est vraiment mais cette
émission j'ai qu'une seule réaction me
l'avoir ce type là qui pleurait avec ses
1 millions de vues ça me fait jamais
merci renaud girard est bien sûr cet
hommage au président peyrefitte nous
allons à prendre l'antenne à vous
cognacq jay
[Musique]